boa noite a todos
a norma apresentada aqui pra conversar
com vocês e eu decidi contar uma
história a história de um menino nascido
em áfrica um continente que dizer
africano e que naquela altura que nasceu
que era muito e pouco desenvolvida e
essa história que vou tentar contar pra
você porque porque basicamente o homem é
do tamanho do seu sonho e esse menino
tinha um sonho um sonho a realizar se
ela consegue realizar ou não dependem
muito dela e do meio ambiente do meu
livro três marcos foram principais na
vida desse menino 1966 1968 e 1993
eu vou explicar cada um deus porque 1966
nesse que era observou salazar naquela
altura
simplesmente foi abordado por temas como
biologia como todos nós somos física
química matemática português latim já
não existe mais nada que o tempo existia
e também na mesma altura eu tinha um
passado por um problema de saúde em que
todos nós naquela altura epidérmico
endêmico naquela altura que era a
paralisia infantil poliomielite que
tenha sido operado em 1966 e duas coisas
uma é que como eu gostava de história e
geografia e isso era algo que para mim
era extremamente importante
muito mais do que a biologia muito mais
do que matemática porque a história me
acrescentar alguma coisa então além das
disciplinas que eu tinha eu tenho
procurado avidamente livros pra poder
ver o que eu gostava
as civilizações antigas da civilização
romana da civilização grega de tudo
aquilo que era nos dado naquela altura
pra ver e mais do que isso
a geografia é importante porque
geografia importante porque ia eu
conhecia países diferentes com culturas
diferentes e naquela altura se você for
recordar 1966 nós inconcebivelmente
naquela altura nós não tínhamos internet
nós não tínhamos nada era tudo
pesquisado através do livro e esse é um
grande ponto então isso foi muito
importante pra mim esse ponto juntamente
com essa cirurgia que eu sofri o fui
submetido melhor dizendo
nessa altura da paralisia infantil me
despertaram duas coisas primeiro eu
quero ser médico e se era uma só se
podem ver que eu tinha nessa altura com
11 anos que é difícil as pessoas
chegarem dizer o que querem ser com 11
antes disso quero ser médica e outra
coisa que eu quero fazer é que
basicamente eu quero viajar pelo mundo
eu quero conhecer o mundo e isso pra mim
era muito importante com 11 anos pelas
geografia sempre foi para mim um ponto
eu quero conhecer essa parte do mundo
mas isso não se consegue sem nenhum
trabalho e se não consegui consegue
fazer este projeto se sony tem que ser
desenvolvido numa outra maneira
ele tem que ser desenvolvido por parte
da primeira parte que eu tinha que ter
era ser médico quando em 1968
eu estava em casa dos meus pais e nós
tínhamos um primo tinha passado eu vivi
em moçambique naquela altura eu tenho um
primo que era cirurgião cardiovascular e
tenha feito no serviço de grupos por
ross que estão na cidade do cabo
junto com o professor barnard com 11
fiel à digamos ou pelo menos que ele
tivesse ficavam parte do tempo vendo
esses sejam para christian barnard do
ano anterior
fez o primeiro transplante cardíaco no
mundo
então nessa altura eu estava no pico da
fama de ter sido o primeiro cirurgião
cardiovascular a fazer o transplante
perdi meu primo era cirurgião
cardiovascular em lisboa foi lá ficar
seis meses e passou 1 em casa e tivemos
um jantar de família e nessa ocasião ele
escreveu o que era o o o cirurgia
cardíaca num e o que era o transplante
perder
são imagens do poço para vencer fazendo
a retirada do órgão de uma uma moça que
tinha acabado de ter um acidente de
carro e teve morte encefálica e
basicamente dizer deus fazendo o
transplante
isso aqui é um museu que existe na
cidade do cabo dentro do hospital grupo
escuta e naquela noite
pra mim foi essencial porque eu decidi
que além de querer fazer medicina eu
queria fazer cirurgia cardiovascular
então eu tinha 13 anos naquela altura e
prosseguir meu sonho
e aí começou o sony todo porque o que eu
queria eu queria basicamente tentar
consertar corações
vocês não sabem qual é a felicidade de
uma pessoa de ter um coração na mão
poucos de vocês vão ter essa
possibilidade apenas aqueles que
tentarem seguir mas é realmente é uma
das coisas melhores que tem na vida pelo
menos para mim poder fazer isso
e pra isso eu tive que ter uma sequência
grande enorme porque eu entrei medicina
que dizer eu acabei saindo de portugal e
vindo pra cá
então tudo isso que eu vim pro pro
universidade federal do paraná em
curitiba
acabei fazendo a minha residência em
curitiba também e depois voltei para
alguns
durante esse tempo inteiro não se eu
sempre me dediquei à cirurgia cardíaca e
era aquilo que eu gostava de fazer a e
cada vez
a paixão foi maior mas vejam todo mundo
disse que se você trabalhar em algo que
seja prazeroso que te dê prazer você
nunca mais vai trabalhar
eu não sei se isso é verdade mas o que
eu sei é que basicamente
tem algumas coisas que eu vi primeiro
trabalhar em equipe é uma das melhores
coisas que têm segundo eu vou contar
algumas histórias que acontecem porque é
bom ser cirurgião cardiovascular
por que por exemplo um dos casos que
acontecem teve um paciente que passou no
meu consultório e que tem simplesmente
precisa ser operado porque tenho essa
doença eo vice prefeito e se eu precisar
ser operado com uma certa urgência
eu me disse mas em 30 dias a minha casa
e eu vou levá lo a voltar disse
promessas eu não posso fazer mas existem
grandes possibilidades e não tem nada
melhor na vida que você saber que aquilo
vôo levou a neta para o altar
depois de uma cirurgia cardiovascular
outro exemplo que eu dou pra vocês é
você ter uma criança com 480 gramas
nascida o reinado uma doença cardíaca
congênita e que precisa ser tratado
porque você sabe que se não for tratado
nos primeiros dias de vida
provavelmente essa crença não consiga
chegar à maioridade
mas mais do que operar e pegar no
coração resolver o problema é você ver
45 anos depois essa criança vindo com a
mãe que agradecer
isso sim é que é confortável não é o
trabalho trabalho estressante
o trabalho é duro e você tava o tempo
inteiro trabalhando para isso
falaram um pouco nesse esporte
esse estoque acontece que tinha um tricô
da que era um aparelho que resolver
todos os problemas da nossa de tudo em
seu avanço da medicina é grande corrente
que nós temos
o que acontece é inteligência artificial
vai nos trazer isso também
então esse é o futuro mas dentro da
medicina uma coisa que eu digo é que
repita as palavras do professor adib
jatene é que a função do médico e curado
mas quando eu não puder curar eu pelo
menos precisa aliviar e quando não
puderam nem curar e aliviar precisa sem
dúvida confortável consciente e mais do
que isso
apesar da inteligência artificial o
médico precisa ser um especialista em
pessoas e essa é a grande diferença
em média ocorrem dia
a terceira parte em 1983
esse homem aqui ele é basicamente é
filho de uma família a não pobre mas
também não era rica 01 11 irmãos e foi o
único dos 11 irmãos que conseguiu fazer
um curso superior e depois do
experimento estrado e doutorado
mas foi ele que me ensina o que é o
ensino e foi ele que me ensinou os
primeiros passos da mãe ea partir de
eu entrei dentro dessa grande escola da
vida que é o ensino eo ensino superior
e aí eu passei por quatro foram dados
quatro faculdades de medicina eu fui
professora evangélica fui profissional
não é esta
sou profissional com a no centro
universitário vaga e foi professor da
universidade federal do paraná e isso
realmente mostrou isso realmente mostrou
que houve uma grande diferença
eu me lembro nos primeiros anos em que
eu era professor e nós temos de ir atrás
do livro pra fazer um trabalho
científico por exemplo você correr atrás
livros não existia mais nada hoje
hoje nós temos sem dúvida toda a
informação do mundo nac
isso aqui é um computador que não é um
telefone
como isso aqui não é mais um relógio em
mais do que uma função e nós temos tudo
aqui hoje em dia e nós temos que ver que
essas novas gerações de frente do norte
também são diferentes
a geração que eu pertenço à geração baby
boom uma é muito diferente da geração se
hoje em dia já não sei que era
resultados imediatos
nós não conseguimos pensar dessa maneira
então o que acontece que ser você tem
que ter uma maneira diferente charles
darwin dizia que quem sobrevive hoje no
mundo não é nem mais forte nem mais
inteligente você quer você tá melhor a
mudança
então aquilo que tem abílio que abriu
para fazer qualquer coisa e ser abril
depende também da idade porque o que
acontece todas as idades você tem que
ser avó
e aí você cria habilidade em cima de
você poder fazer essa transformação
e como é que isso acontece a educação
num educação acontece
porque você precisa aprender todo dia
você precisa aprender
existem mudanças no aprendizado que você
tem hoje em dia o que hoje é uma
realidade amanhã pode não ser
então você precisa aprender aquilo que
você aprendeu anteriormente para voltar
a aprender novamente o que é realidade e
é esse o ensino que nós temos hoje em
dia nós precisamos fazer essa mudança
toda principalmente para gerações novas
que não nos entendem mas existem uma
mudança que tem que ser feita para os
professores mas também existe uma
mudança que tem que ser feito com os
outros
então o que eu acho eu acho que todos
nós temos que ser residentes o
suficiente e as pessoas que estão
começando e precisam acreditar na sua
força interior porque é ela que nos vai
levar a algum lugar é ela que nos vai
levar um sonho que nós tivemos e mais do
que isso no seu potencial e crerem que
nós somos capazes de vencer aqui o que
nós queremos
e aí eu coloco quase toda que eu sonho
de criança que eu tinha e viajar pelo
mundo e que eu ainda não fiz todo mas
também não terminei a minha vida então
ainda tem algum caminho a percorrer e
exceções parte que eu já conheço ainda
falta um pouco mas ainda tem mais alguns
anos
e pra isso pra você ter esse equilíbrio
na vida você precisa pelo menos na parte
daquilo como professor pelo equilíbrio
entre a pesquisa o equilíbrio com o
ensino e com a assistência que é o
dia-a-dia nosso de tratar de pacientes
mas mais que isso nessas atividades
profissionais
você precisa também ter solidariedade
saber trabalhar em equipe é extremamente
importante hoje que o médico saiba
trabalhar em equipe multidisciplinar que
não trabalha mais no segundo e tudo isso
leva tempo e você tem que quebrar uma
série de paradigmas que existem para
você conseguir chegar lá ter ética
eu não preciso nem dizer eu acho que é
extremamente importante que todos nós
tenhamos é mais do que isso o trabalho o
tempo inteiro num se nós formos a ver
existem esses três pontos pra mim
faltava um ponto que era a parte
associativa junto com ele
essa parte subjetiva eu consegui
realizar ao longo de 18 anos que toda a
sociedade brasileira de cirurgia
cardiovascular até chegar ao ponto
máximo pra mim representou apenas numa
carreira de associativa que a
presidência da sociedade e isso é o
reconhecimento dos teus pais que deixa
muito feliz
mais do que isso ea realização de um
sonho de criança que você começa muitos
anos atrás mas esses são quatro pilares
eu acho importante ver isso são apenas
quatro pilares de um banco
digamos que você precisa um lugar para
sentar
você precisa de um lugar que caracterize
tudo junto e tudo isso e aí é que eu
acho que entra quarta a parte mais
importante que a família e une tudo é
aquela que você chega em casa com algum
11 vezes extremamente eufórica porque
você teve na tua vida profissional um
êxito de um paciente que foi bem mas é o
mesmo as pessoas que quando você chega
em casa com algum problema ou com alguma
frustração e não são poucas as vezes que
pode suportar o tempo inteiro e pode
ajudar a criar se tornou forças pra você
ver a ser aquele excelente entre o
momento em que você volta do estado para
estado normal novamente
então eu acho importante isso aqui e
isso é um dos pontos pra mim primordiais
dentro de toda a vida profissional
você pode ter todos os êxitos que você
tiver se você não tiver essa condição e
suporte todos os outros provavelmente
você não vai ter ninguém na vida e por
um tempo com a transtur por último o que
eu quero deixar para vocês como mensagem
final
são palavras de veículos de josé bini a
ligação é muito grande pelo foi a
primeira pessoa que fez um transplante
cardíaco na américa do sul
ele foi a primeira pessoa que fez um
transplante cardíaco
dentro do brasil e ele dizia que nada
absolutamente nada
trânsito o trabalho e essa é a mensagem
que eu acho mais importante pra todos
nós qualquer que seja evitado que o
trabalho pode demorar tempo como os
alicerces de uma obra demora um tempo
para construir uma obra um prédio grande
sem dúvida se você tiver o trabalho e
continuar trabalhando o tempo inteiro
você vai conseguir e esse trabalho é que
vai levar aquela primeira fase de que o
homem é tão grande como o seu sonho
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]